if i can find
some power in this some way to get
through this
that right there will be the fuel for
the rest of my life once you take
control of your mind
you start making decisions for yourself
versus your mind making decisions for
you through hard work
you can do you can out work anybody
remember how badass they are
but that's the part people don't want to
dive into
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how to
train your mind to never quit with david
goggins
enjoy
let's kick it off with rule number one
overcome yourself i realized that god
wasn't going to give me to get out of
jail free card
and from the time i was born
into the time i was 19 years old
my wife
had these hurdles i constantly hit
obstacles
obstacle after obstacle after obstacle
and
i i had to figure out how to manage
suffering how how to deal with it
because it'd be part of my life forever
at least that's what i thought
so in order to deal with it
i had to be able to conquer it and
overcome it and deal with it know that
in this suffering there has to be some
kind of growth
with every obstacle i look at it as
friction now without friction there is
no growth
you have to have friction in your life
to grow
so i started looking at all these
different things versus the what was me
mentality like oh my god look at my life
my life's so [ __ ] up i come from this
family i'm being beaten i'm being abused
mentally physically
i start looking at it as a as the
perfect trial ground
try to flip it upside down it's okay i'm
suffering tremendously mentally
use this to your advantage versus your
disadvantage so that's what i did versus
looking at it as like oh my god what was
me i'm never gonna get out of here i
looked at okay hang on a second hang on
a second
if i can overcome this
if i can find some power in this some
way to get through this
[Music]
that right there will be the fuel for
the rest of my life
and so i found great strength and
suffering
great strength in it because why through
all of that
it started to callous my mind
over the victim's mentality
this whole thing about suffering
yeah it sucks
really bad
uh really really bad
but we all live
on this side of suffering
on this side this nice box that's very
comfortable that we know when
everything's going to happen we're in it
it's good we know how everything's going
to turn out
it's those few people who are willing to
go on the on this side of suffering
and once they get through that ask him
how he feels now
his mind
how far he grew
in that short period of time
he grew so much more than a normal
person because he was willing to go
outside himself because on the other end
of suffering
is greatness
it's not over here so a whole bunch of
us we put ourselves in this great box
and in that box there's no suffering in
it
so what we do is we is we
result to ourselves
from greatness
so for me for instance i was 300 damn
pounds
at one time in my life
spray for cockroaches made a thousand
dollars a month
i was living in that box
i would sometimes look over the box and
i saw hell suffering storms avalanches
tornadoes i'm gonna go over there but i
knew if i could get through that
mentally
on the other side was 185 pound person
who's a navy seal went through ranger
school only person to do this only
person do that only person do this but
that's through all that
all that i have to go through so you
peek over the box and you go back in and
say oh i'm okay being 300 pounds making
a thousand dollars a month i'm okay over
here
and on the other side is where you start
to really start your journey
people think they start their journey
because they're born
no there's a lot of people in graves who
have lived 100 years
and have never started their real
journey
your real journey starts when you go
outside that box
and you start climbing mountains and
start climbing mountains and you think
at the top of the mountain you go down
the other side everything i'm here you
look up there's another mountain
and it goes on
and it goes on and it goes on and just
when you're getting ready to quit
you crest that final mountain you get
down and you look
and there you are
and it starts to make sense to you then
it doesn't make sense to you until you
get outside that box i'll talk to so
many people and what i say is not for
everybody
so many people don't have any clue on
what the [ __ ] i'm saying because they're
in this box
and it's their brain
you first must go through suffering to
find that great
we're all looking for a lot of us want
to have there's a lot of books out there
about this five steps
do this do this do this get there no man
it's not that easy
to find real permanent peace and
enlightenment
you must go to the dark side of who you
are
i could have easily just shoved my whole
life under a rug and went straight to
peace
are you happy there
you overcame nothing
you jumped hell you skipped hell
for you you forgo
this part of your life you skip it and
go right to peace
so you always have this thing back here
that's haunting you and that's that
darkness
you must go into the darkness to truly
find that light that you're looking for
because that's what's on the other side
of that
people get it all wrong man
you you have to face suffering
you have to face this dark side this
darkness and there's a lot of energy in
there
there's a lot of goodness in there
that you can use to find greatness
but you cannot find your peace you're
looking for in yourself
until you've overcome yourself rule
number two keep getting up growing up
being the kid i was i found strength in
different movies yeah so i come home in
one movie i found a lot of strength as
funny as it may seem but i visualized
this scene i do it today during the
pull-up record i did 4030 pull-ups
the last time i did it actually got it
took me three times i played one song
for 17 hours pretty much
is from this movie
rocky one
round 14.
i related to the person in the movie
but just the one scene
when apollo's beating the [ __ ] out of
rocky
he falls in the corner
and everybody and rocky and paul turns
around arms up happy i i got this guy
he turns around not knowing that rocky's
trying to get up off the canvas
mickey's saying mickey's his trainer
saying stay down everybody's saying you
did good
you did good you had 14 rounds with with
the champ
rocking in here
he got up and what sticks in my mind
today still and i've seen it right now
when he got up
apollo starts to turn around to see the
aftermath of what the fetus destroyed
and he did not expect to see what he saw
right
and what i see uh the whole movie
i see apollo creased face yeah fear
crept in yes
and i said to myself as a young kid
i want to be that
i don't need to win
i don't need trophies i don't need
people to like me i just want what he
has yeah
a fictional character whatever the hell
it was
i want that
and i visualize that
and i want to become the guy who can get
off the canvas and look at somebody who
beat the [ __ ] out of him life
yeah it's about life right now
in life
even life itself pushed her head down
towards david
yeah this
is not going to stop right so that
mentality
became
what i wanted nice
and that's how it started with that
visualization
of the canvas
and all i got to do is just keep getting
up rule number three reprogram your
brain our mind
wants to protect us
the mind is like honestly it has a
tactical advantage over us
it knows our deepest darkest fears or
insecurities it knows where we start to
feel
uh
we start getting that doubt creeping
that says hey man you know what man
maybe this isn't good let's go back home
to the wife let's go back home to the
kids this is not comfortable so in that
moment the mind directs us it's a
protective mechanism it saves us for
doing bodily harm or
or it really saves us from discovering
that the mind's like i want to be in
charge of you
i don't want you to be in charge of me
so it tells you let's just stop right
here
but once you start breaking through that
barrier
and start breaking down that governor
the governor that you've put in your
mind
because we forget we
are in control of our mind
we believe it's the other way around
no
we put in our minds what we should do
but we believe our mind is telling us
it's giving us all this feedback
we have to reprogram it and tell us no
no no we're good
we're good we go this sucks
but it's okay rule number four take
control of your mind i'm the only person
in the history of navy so trained to go
through three hell weeks in one year can
you explain a little bit what hell week
it is because i i i heard it on your
audiobook a lot yes and it just sounds
like a painful moment that very few
people are able to handle it it is a
very long painful moment so
i don't know what week it is but for me
it was my third week
and sometimes it's your third fourth or
fifth week in navy seal training
navy still training six months long
and this is like the biggest crucible in
navy so it probably in all the special
forces you know special ops
it's 130 hours
of continuous training
and you might get two hours of sleep
and the whole idea is you start on
sunday
and you end on friday you might get two
hours of sleep and the whole idea of
this train is to get a man
and break him down to nothing
and that's where you see what a man is
made of
so to make it through one
most people say
i'm never going back through again
so
i was fortunate god blessed me so i
started looking at at these failures as
blessings
because with all with all these failures
and all these bullies and all these
being abused and all in my learning
disabilities and stuttering and
everything i had in my life
they are really gifts yeah they're gifts
and it's not some psychological babble
[ __ ] i'm using to say oh no my life
wasn't that bad no my life sucked
but they truly were gifts because all
these different
trials and tribulations
led my mind to where it's at now
so um hell week once again 130 hours
you get two hours of sleep maybe and
they beat this guy beating like push-ups
sit-ups
and it's um near the pacific ocean so
you're out
in the pacific ocean back in and that
water's freezing
and so you see these men these great men
that i watched on tv
i'm now with them
and for the longest time i put people
who had better childhoods better grades
better this better that i put them all
above me
but now i'm on the same playing field as
them so when you get on the same playing
field as these men who you think are
better than you
you look at them eye to eye
and you realize that they're not
so once again i'm starting to do all
this live autopsy
like saying god man
you remind yourself your whole life
thinking that this person came from a
nicer house better education better mom
better dad and they're better than you
it's not the case
you have this in you you may have to dig
a little deeper to find it
you know their their family may have
started them off a lot better than you
but it's there yeah it's there so i
started really realizing how powerful
the mind was in that third hell week so
i went down to the gym and there's this
like
crazy elliptical trainer but it's not a
normal elliptical trainer it's one that
you like almost self-power and it's very
yeah it's not electric you know yeah
very difficult yeah so i got on that
thing and i realized man this [ __ ] sucks
and after like two minutes like i don't
want to do this
so
right then i realized hmm
it looks like we're gonna be here for a
while
so i did that for two hours and 45
minutes wow yeah so
i'm not saying do that but that's
something i did today once my mind said
you know what let's not do this today
i said well since we're my mind went
there i redirected and said just for
having that weak thought
we're going to be on here for a while
right so it does sort of sound like
you're punishing
part of your
mind in a way
punishment may not be the right word
i want my mind to know who's in charge
so for the better part of 26 years
my mind was in charge of me yeah which
is why i made all these horrible
decisions once you take control of your
mind
you start making decisions for yourself
versus your mind making decisions for
you
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five out work everyone
where i got my work ethic from
was the hours i had to spend learning
this
when you sit down and you're not smart
you have a disability yeah
and you still want to be in the top of
your class i didn't want to get by
when i realized that i can learn do hard
work
and i can beat the valedictorian in
school but i got put in 10 hours more a
day than he does you know what kind of
strength comes from that when you're
sitting down that guy that that
valedictorian study for an hour and you
know i caught you
i caught you and i am dumb
but i have the work ethic to catch you
that's where david gaga's got really
invented yeah was at a kitchen table
with 20 spiral notebooks that were empty
and then three months later
yeah they were full
and when you can go through that i still
have them in my storage unit you're
going through these spiral notebooks of
your life
and you realize this is how i learned
this is unbelievable there's no miles
it's not about the miles it's that
having a discipline every day they say
for me to learn this one math problem
it's gonna take me 10 hours wow
and that's where it and you realize
through hard work
you can do you can out work anybody
remember how badass they are
but that's the part people don't want to
dive into rule number six develop a
crazy work ethic different mindset i
turn negatives into positives
so i would i would take like who who
would even think about doing this so i
would sit in my couch saying who at 297
who can't swim that great who's scared
of the water would have the balls
clear the balls to man up quit a job and
go and to put everything on himself
so it's how i started talking to myself
and putting myself in a whole different
category and that would fuel me the next
day and i just kept using that as fuel
and fuel no one would do this no one do
this you're the best around you're the
best ever live
and i had i kept fueling me with the
with the right kind of message that i
needed to hear that i was never telling
myself and through time
it became reality
to myself
so
you start out on the first day and then
do you start running again the second
day yeah the second day went right back
after it again but i started realizing i
can't run that far right so what i did
was i became damn near a professional
cyclist with the miles i put on the bike
so i never
whenever i watched tv
i had to be doing something so i was
riding the bike i rode a bike a lot to
to lose the first initial kind of weight
because my bones were just hurting so
bad my body was broken and i learned to
get over that also and i try to swim a
lot i want a great swimmer but putting
fins on kind of equalized my body i
wasn't so negative buoyant so i started
fitting a whole bunch and i spent hours
in the pool hours in the pool trying to
get more and more comfortable not
because i was going underwater i was so
scared of the water that i had to live
in the water
i had to become one with the water so
going to the pool used to scare me
so i went to the pool an awful awful lot
and then the bike got easier i was able
to run more i went from like one mile
one mile was a great accomplishment two
miles and then from two to three was a
big one then i went from three to six
and then like they have a warning order
that they give people to get ready for
buds and the whole thing was running six
miles five days a week
and that was my goal
and so i just kept
i failed i go back to scratch i used
some positive motivation i had like one
day when i like defeated
but i started realizing this is part of
the process this is part of the journey
i had to realize this is part of my
process versus just saying like i used
to i'm just not good enough
if i'm not good enough we always say
that it's not good enough and then we
try something else
i'm gonna make myself good enough
and that became my mentality i wanna i'm
gonna make myself good enough
and so i misunderstood a lot
but that's that's all it came down to i
made myself good enough
and the days i couldn't run that far the
next week
i would do two a days
so like on the running if i ran a
quarter a mile
i waited a couple hours it'd haunt me
bother me i try to win a half a mile
next time same day
you can do more than this if i had to
walk i had to walk it just became just a
process of grinding and grinding and
grinding not even a good word for it
it's not even a good word for it
and just just going further and further
and then when i got through running i go
to the bike i go to the pool if i got
tired somewhere my legs are tired i go
to the gym and i develop this crazy
workout where i was doing volume like
two three hundred reps of like very
light weight people say hey you know how
come you don't have any like loose skin
my workout routine in the gym became
sick
it became sick i was just doing two
three hundred reps 400 reps
on like chest just like for one simple
exercise the bench press
and i rack it get back on it just rep it
out trying to burn as many calories as i
can build that muscle mass and i just
became just became obsessed with it rule
number seven stop feeling sorry for
yourself when i turned that spanish
notebook in so i was in spanish class
obviously opened my notebook up and said
[ __ ] we're going to kill you had a
drawing of me and actually talk to the
principal because i'm in the process of
writing my book right now his name is
kurt freeman yeah i talked to him two
days ago no kidding he said i remember
like like it was yesterday so i left my
class
um just didn't tell a teacher went right
to his office and showed him it and he
said
and i wasn't a good speller at all
obviously i
copied and they spelled [ __ ] niger
i know i spoiled [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying they they spell [ __ ] niger
so um he looked at me and said they're
ignorant and that's the best advice he
can give me my mom's working three jobs
um i was
a lasky kid i was i was on my own
i did my own thing man i missed almost
all my junior year of high school
knowing school just did my own thing
and um
that was a turning point when i really
realized i was on my own
i mean it just kind of hit me like the
best advice you can give me is that
spelled [ __ ] niger
and pretty much you know i think he
called my mom up and i went back to
class
and i realized that life isn't fair it's
not fair and you better figure out some
tools and some ways to stop feeling
sorry for yourself because no one is
coming to rescue you no one feels sorry
for you right and at the end of the day
no one really cared about me that's how
it felt that was the reality of it rule
number eight build mental toughness seal
training became pretty hard and a lot of
guys weren't getting through it
so they designed a seal pet prep program
like a boot camp for the boot camp
that's right yeah and it was two months
in my last two years before i retired
from the military they sent me there to
train these kids wow to get ready for
people between 19 20 years ago young
kids
so when they get to navy seal training
man they were physical studs
they were running swimming i mean they
were they were hybrids wow
but they get the buds
and the same amount of people would quit
why is that
this is why
we were training bigger stronger faster
quitters
hmm
it's not about not the mind that's right
we weren't diving into the sewer
everybody's got a story
we don't share it on social media
we share our nice life on social media
we have we all have a dungeon i'm just
willing to talk about mine yeah most of
us aren't willing to talk about it i
want to talk about my dungeon
i wasn't getting into the dungeon of
these guys minds
i wasn't building that so-called mental
toughness mental toughness isn't
something that you
sample is something that you live in
every day
so when something hard would happen to
these kids like in hell week
it would draw on something that made
them very insecure
and they look for comfort whenever
hardness comes and you don't know what
it is it may be different for you than
this for me
but you go back to your insecurities
and then when you go back to the
insecurities you then look for comfort
within those insecurities
and we all look for that cookie that
your mom used to give you when you were
sad when you were sick
we look for our wife or our husband we
look for comfort
it's in those moments
you must retrain your mind
to think differently in hell
i wasn't training them to do that
why weren't you training i wasn't
training myself yet because at that time
i was doing what i was told
these guys needed me a standard physical
standard a physical standard
the physical standard is not what they
need to meet
it's a mental standard you must meet in
life
so going back to when i was sick
i was hitting the physical standards
i wasn't meeting
the mental standard the mental standard
is you must know how far you've come wow
i wasn't
i i had come
8 thousand miles from where i started
but if you never know that you're still
in the seven dollar a month place
when i was sick i was able to slow it
down
and reflect back on my entire life
and in that bed and i thought i was
dying because that story is long that
that sick person in my life is long
i didn't care if i died or lived
wow because i was for the first time in
my life happy wow and that peace
because i reflected back on where it
started rule number nine develop
discipline i prioritize
trying to win the battle in the morning
so i always win the battle of morning so
i get morning time every morning i go
for a run
that's the first thing i do every
morning haven't taken a day off of
running since
december 2016.
i've every day up in the morning so i
also stretch out
every day for about two to three hours
every day i've missed two days in about
five and a half six years
so
that's just my routine and about four
days a week i'm in the gym hitting the
weights
because you know you can't just be a
runner so this is every single day
the the monotony in my life
but this is what builds discipline
you know and not everybody i'm not
telling everybody to do this but this is
my lifestyle this is how i build
self-discipline and rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is be present i have to be very
present in everything i do like right
now i'm a rich role
i'm not thinking about
but rich roll and what the [ __ ] coming
out of your mouth right now
that's what that's what gives me a huge
advantage in life especially today in
this day and age with so much going so
fast and everybody wants to keep
everything going everything up and
everything i want to be the greatest you
know the greatest multitasker of all
time not me
if i put my hundred percent into what's
in front of me i will destroy it if i'm
out here just multitasking this i'm
gonna half-ass everything i do
so that's it is the most important thing
the word of me is being focused at the
task at hand now i've got a special
bonus clip that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week when you watch a video and
just get motivated the science says you
have a 35 chance of actually following
through on your goals that's not good
enough no not for you believe nation we
got to do something but when you write
it down and you create a specific plan
of action for the next week that number
jumps to 91 chance of you following
through and when you commit to somebody
else like leaving a comment on this
video it jumps to 95 you need to follow
through on your goals so what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your specific plan of action for the
next week put it down the comments below
so i can celebrate you well there's
something i invented a long time ago
and when you have nothing to draw from
i was able to find strength in every
molecule of this earth
i'm able to be in a room with nothing
with no motivation no inspiration
nothing and find it
so what i did in those situations was i
invented this thing called taking souls
when everybody's all [ __ ] up and
you're exhausted and you're weak and
you're tired and you're looking around
and everybody looks as bad as you or
even worse
i'm like you know what i want to now
make a statement
it's the perfect time to make a
statement to make a statement to let you
know where your life ends
and mine begins
and so the statement there is i must
drop every bit of strength from their
looks on their faces
and how they feel
and how i'm gonna now
from my childhood where i came from
how's the bottom of the barrel i'm now
amongst all these uncommon people i'm
now going to now make you feel like
you're common
so i use their
their sadness their weakness their
parts of their life for god this sucks
i'm like all poopy pants to messed up i
use that for my strength
and i have this moment of like
let's say we're
in the sand running or whatever i will
do a surge i would do something
everybody's like how the [ __ ] is he
doing this
and from that that look on their face
that feeling of god man this guy must be
something something special it then
surges me further and further and faster
and harder for a long time
so
it's energy is everywhere
but the thing is it's so loud
that that that voice in your head of
pain and suffering and discomfort and i
don't want to do this it's so loud
that you're unable to really calm it
down and say okay there's something here
it's a patient calm that you have to
bring yourself to say i know i have
something here but that voice is so
powerful that i just want you just to
let's leave right we're done we're done
it spazzes you out and you want to go
versus saying let's take a second hang
on before we spaz the [ __ ] out hang on
and in that moment you can think clearly
and find that strength out there for you
my first time going through buds i got
the hell week
um stress fractures double pneumonia
i got rolled back day one week one
second time going through buds i
actually
um fractured my patella
before i got into hell week
made it through hell week with a
fractured patella went two weeks after
hell week and then because why i didn't
want to get rolled back to day one week
one
but i couldn't keep up with the class
got rolled back to day one week one
after hell week and then i went through
my third time and i graduated that class
we had a guy die in that third hell week
class 235 it's just life man i mean
you know when i was born you know i was
a good kid
and life beat the [ __ ] out of me for no
reason
but it's up to us
it's up to us now no one's coming back
to save you
so you better start to to armor your
mind against the things that are gonna
come at you it's not always your fault
but you gotta suck at the [ __ ] up
and you gotta deal with it so that's why
i believe in that structure system
because basically all you're trying to
do
is develop the right mindset
to attack every obstacle you're going to
face in life
that's all the structure is about
it's about setting up a structure system
in your life so you can attack you know
attack the obstacles that are going to
come at you
that's that's basically what it's about
how do i gain more confidence it starts
with yourself man you got to start
diving into those things that you are
afraid of
you don't gain confidence by going to
the spot that makes you feel good
it's to be a false reality
and the second life gives you that
challenge
all you want to do is go back to what
makes you confidence or or or what gave
you confidence is that happy spot no
what gives you confidence what gave me
confidence was spending years at a
kitchen table
trying to learn how to read and write on
my own
realizing i can't learn the way you
learn i can't
but i can learn what gives you
confidence not being afraid
it's overcoming the fear
isis stutters severely bad so right now
i don't know how many people are going
to watch this you know what gives me
confidence is knowing i no longer care
if i sit or start stuttering to you yeah
that's what gives me confidence is
facing these things overcoming them and
maybe not overcoming them every day
but facing them
and facing their face and preaching like
this you know what man this is where
it's at
it's not in that comfort zone
it's in the discomfort zone is where my
confidence is getting built mm-hmm
that's where it's getting built
but people want to and they want an
easier answer yeah there has to be an
easier way
there's not i'm sorry i searched for it
my entire life the water's too cold
the sun's too hot
i'm getting up too early why am i doing
this to myself
that's what the normal mind says
i had to start training my mind to think
about
how the f
can i get through this
not giving myself a way out
never give myself creating a wall around
all the [ __ ] ways out in my mind
i just slowly started to build this
[ __ ] wall so my mind knew
this [ __ ] is not going to give
himself away out of here in my first
tail week i had a huge setback
i was broken
my legs were broken i had double
pneumonia
i got rolled back to day one week one of
navy seal training
i got through that second hell week
during the second hell week i actually
broke my knee i continued to limp around
for a couple weeks
i couldn't make it anymore got rolled
back to day one week one
i'll never forget standing there in
front of captain bowen he was the ceo in
charge of navy seal training at the time
and he had no mercy on anybody
if he believed in
managing your expectations
i wouldn't be here today he challenged
me again
i was challenged my whole life not by
the mindset of managing expectations by
exceeding expectations not by managing
them i'm standing there
with crutches
i'm sitting in his office he looks at me
he goes dog is this your last time
we're gonna put you through navy seal
training
this will be your third hell week in one
year
we're not gonna put you through a fourth
so this is your last time
i'm thinking how am i gonna get through
this
i'm i'm badly jacked up my legs are
broken my knee is messed up
and he goes you have a couple of months
to get better
a couple months isn't going to do it
i won't get healed up in a couple of
months
but i realized i'm going to get through
this
i'm gonna find a way to get through it
because why i put barriers in my mind
so my third hell week i went in there
with pretty much i would put a black
sock
on first
i would get duct tape
and i duct taped my ankles all the way
up to my calf every single morning and
then i put another black sock over it
and what that did that prevented me
from moving
my ankle
so i didn't really out i wasn't flexing
my shin as much
and i started running with just my hip
flexors
in this hell week it was a bad help we
had a guy die on thursday morning of
hell week
i went on to become a navy seal
greatness is not something that you meet
once
it's something that you meet
thousands of times in your life and you
don't reach it
if you're not constantly in constant
pursuit of
greatness
so if my mind were to say right now
i'm great
i just lost
we're going to grow
we're not going to triple down on our
strengths
we're not going to do that crap
we're going to work on our weaknesses so
we grow we need friction to do that
without friction there's no growth
without friction there's confusion
confusion is david goggins how did you
become who you are today
i put a bunch of friction in my life
and i grew
that's how i did it you know you get
mentally tough
it's a lifestyle
instead of hitting that news button in
the morning and not making your bed not
cleaning your house
you don't hit this news button
you get up you don't want to go run you
go run you don't want to go swimming you
go swim you don't make your beds you
make your bed you don't want to clean
your house and clean your house you
don't want to study study that's how you
start to callous your mind so that
became my life
if you say you're gonna wake up at four
o'clock in the morning to go run
wake up at four o'clock and it's gonna
suck
it's not gonna be fun do something that
sucks every single day of your life
that's how you grow
embrace the suck i walked in when 297 he
looked at me strangely and i said i want
to be a seal
and lucky enough the guy looked at me
and said
let's see what we can do
he weighed me i weighed 106 pounds
overweight the guy said man
there's a program that it's about to end
that you can go
and if you make it through buds you then
go active duty right and you'll be a
seal if not you come to [ __ ] home right
i was like
yeah
so anyway
he gonna make y'all lose 106 pounds less
than three months the first thing about
it was so i said to myself i'm gonna run
four miles
my first run off the gate
i'm gonna run four miles i ran a mile i
went a quarter of a mile
walked home sat on the couch depressed
i said man there's no way i can do this
but what i realized though
is i wasn't going to give up
because i've already given up many times
and i thought about how would i feel at
50 years old if you gave up if i gave up
now
not to have you know so i kept all this
stuff in my mind
and um
basically i started becoming obsessed
slowly it didn't happen that night on
the couch right over a period of time i
started becoming obsessed with
studying with weight with being somebody
was making people who thought it was
gonna be nothing
kind of like feel like i became obsessed
with you have to make this right
and the only person could do is yourself
so i became obsessed with just
being obsessed
[Music]
when you think that you are done you're
only 40
into what your body's capable of doing
and that's just a limit that that we put
ourselves
got our leader of the 150 mile coming in
mr david
he's just won the 280
you never really know how i feel i'll
never really tell you the truth i'm
always going to feel good he's the
person
i want to feel and show you no weakness
congratulations thanks a lot man 150
mile champion first place new course
record
way to go congratulations
i'm never happy and satisfied with
one thing i do it's always a continuous
journey and in all my races
there's never end they just kind of fall
in together i started figuring out going
through buds
was that
the harder something is
the more it was challenging my mind
so i had to find different ways to stay
in the fight in the state of the fight
it got me tougher and tougher and
tougher so i'm actually happy i went
through three hell weeks i never
examined myself
and as a human being you gotta examine
yourself and uh like and i guess the
best place to examine yourself is navy
seal hell week
three times so i got to examine myself a
few times
so it started there it started in hell
week
and it's still going now at 43 years old
i never thought in my wildest dreams
i could be a navy seal
it's until you opened your mind
open-mindedness creates that we all shut
down our mind like for instance
when i broke the pull-up record
everybody around me who heard the
pull-up record was four thousand and
twenty pull-ups
that's the first thing they did oh my
god
four thousand and twenty-four hours or
yeah it's 4 000 20 pull-ups and 24-hour
period yeah yeah
the first thing i did versus closing my
mind you're like oh my god that's crazy
i went and got a penny okay how many is
that every minute exactly every hour
every second instead of taking life and
make it out to be
this grandiose thing start breaking it
down
start breaking it down and
most of us
we live in a box
and we don't want to go outside that box
at all
ever
outside that box
is all these possibilities of life
what we do is we shackle our mind we are
a prisoner in our own mind this is all i
can do this is all i'm good at
and we we we take away the possibility
of you could be this you could be that
yeah you could be all these things
and i never thought that 300 pounds i
could be negative wow so if my mind was
shackled
me and you would never meet
there'd be no book right there'd be no
book right
there'd be nothing
so
what people understand is that they live
for themselves not knowing that you have
the power within yourself to change
millions of lives yeah by face of life
you once said that if you were growing
up in this generation that you would
have a field day because you would take
their souls what did you mean by that
the younger generation quits
not everybody
so i gotta i gotta put that people get
their butt hurt so not everybody
most of this generation quits the second
they get
talked to
you did this wrong you did this wrong or
or they get yelled at it's so easy to
you know to to be great nowadays because
everybody else is most people are weak
this this is a softened generation so if
you have any mental toughness
any any ability if you have any fraction
of self-discipline the ability to
not want to do it but still do it people
have a hard thing understand i hate to
run
and and what makes me so crazy it
doesn't mean more is people
why do you run if you hate it what are
you talking about
i don't want to take showers and eat
either i hate that too
the whole that's a life man
that and and it it wasn't until i
changed that mentality that i became
somebody
i hated going to school so guess what i
was dumb
that's what
one plus one is two
but if you can get through
to doing things that you hate to do
on the other side is greatness
that's what people understand
by me running i am callous in my mind
i'm not training for a race
i'm training for life
i'm training for the time when i get
that two o'clock in the morning call
that my mom is dead or something happens
tragic in life
i don't fall apart
i'm training my mind and my body my
spirit so it's all one so i can handle
what life is gonna throw at me because
the life i've lived it throws a whole
bunch at you
and if you're not physically immensely
prepared for that
you're just gonna crumble and you're
good for nobody
talk to me about what it takes to be on
one side of a door in iraq or anywhere
knowing on the other side of the door
people who are not afraid of you
they're ready for you to come in and you
still have and they have guns and you
still have to breach that door
that's that's a great question it
that's
a very scary situation when you are
on one side of the door
and your mind is racing because on the
other side of that door
it could be no one
it could be four guys with four ak-47s
that
that door you're about to open can be
booby trapped so once you open it boom
your legs are gone
so
there's a thousand things you think
about when you're the first guy second
guy third guy getting ready to go in a
room and flood it and that's why i talk
about the warrior mentality and that's
why so many people
are lost
when i start talking
you have
the right
you're lucky
that you don't have to think like
warriors think you're very privileged i
chose this world to be a warrior and i
would choose it again if i came back to
this world
but the mentality of a warrior is very
different than normal mentality
you must be that person on that door oh
get ready to open it thinking to
yourself
if i die
so be it
the only way you can go in that door is
knowing there's a great chance you're
going to die like being a seal you train
with live ammo
you jump on the airplane every
everything you do
you could die
so to be a warrior why people don't
understand me i'm glad you don't
understand me merry christmas good on
you because being a warrior takes a
whole different mindset
a whole different mindset to know that
there's a great chance i may not beat
him like i was in for 21 years i'm lucky
i'm very lucky that i'm alive able to
talk to you able to still run
but when you sign up on that dialogue to
be upset like a seal your mentality
changes
i may not live
you gotta accept that
and that's the mentality you have
and that's what makes you a warrior if
you're scared to die
you're a bad warrior i hated jumping out
of airplanes
i hated shooting guns
i hated the job as a navy seal
but i did it because i wanted to
change
myself everything i do i'm not really
comfortable doing
but if you choose to go that route to go
be a navy seal
you might as well go be the hardest in
the world
because if you're choosing to do
something you have two routes you can go
there and be a little a little weak
person and get through barely and that's
your reputation
or you can go through
the hardest guy you can possibly be a
nice reputation so my whole thing is if
you're going to choose to open that door
in iraq or afghanistan open the mother
go in hard
because they're going to remember you
by slowly opening it and peeking in
so if you're going to open it and you
made the mind open it don't crack it
open open the door go in that's with
life
if you're choosing to do if you're
choosing to do something attack it
because they're going to remember you
as not attacking it so i want to be
remembered you can hate me there's one
thing you can't say about me
i didn't attack it
so that's the mentality you have if
you're gonna do something you might as
well attack it because you could do it
anyway right
do you use that in civilian life like do
you still
employ that i'm going to attack it i'm
going to take their souls like how does
that play out in a non
combat
zone it still works for me in in life as
far as attacking things
because uh no matter what i want to you
know no matter what avenue i choose i
want to be the very best
and the very best may not be
i'm number one
the very best is did i leave everything
inside of me
out there
so attacking is not like oh i want to
win this or win that or be the best
the best is i'm i'm running against
myself in everything i do
and and that's and that's what i attack
i attack myself
i'm always questioning myself well
everybody it's groundhog's day again for
david goggins
if you pan it down here
you see it's about three o'clock in the
morning
and there's not a car or a person inside
if you pan over here
it's the same thing not a car or a
person in sight
people want to know where i find my
strength at where i get my strength i
get it from a lot of places but right
now this morning
i'm getting it from there's not a
[ __ ] that's up there's not a car
there's not a person everybody's in
their bed sleep dreading that it's a
monday hey this a monday and i'm loving
it i'm loving that while everybody's
getting weaker i'm getting stronger
it's not about the running the swimming
to push up to sit-ups it's about what
those things do for your mentality you
don't get better on the daggone couch
you get better by coming out here and
getting the [ __ ] after it every daggone
day
stay hard i often talk about taking
souls
this morning
this person i usually train alone
this person wanted to run with me
and i said fine we'll run 15.
this morning comes there's storms coming
in this way
and the person calls and said hey
why don't we do it tomorrow
taking souls is when i told him
i'm gonna run 15 today and i'll run with
you again tomorrow
that's what taking souls is about
don't worry about the elements and
what's going on
you got to get out there and get it
and that's taking souls and obviously
he wasn't the only one
that felt about taking the day off
because the storm's coming in right now
and there's not a soul out here but me
you genuinely are legit bad ass at one
point in time you were a legit terrified
person yes so what was the process like
how did how did you step forth
well it's a it's a long process right
um i
my dad beat the [ __ ] on me i was growing
up we i was the first black baby born in
this hospital called miller fillmore in
buffalo new york
my dad owned skating rinks he owned bars
he ran prostitutes from canada to
buffalo new york my dad was a big time
pimp big time anything bad about a
person big time hustler he was american
you know that i'm with him daniel
washington he was that but not that bad
right you know he wasn't that big but
that's what it reminds me of he was that
kind of guy
and beat the [ __ ] out of me did you see
how you know out of my mom there was an
incident one time when my mom got
knocked out on top of the stairs and he
drug her down the stairs by her hair
and at six years old
i'll never forget this
in my mind i was always afraid
my whole life i was afraid i had this
voice this this conscience that would
always be battling me saying hey you got
to get up and do something i didn't want
to do
you know like i was just afraid but
i would that voice would force me to get
up and my dad you know i try to beat him
up whatever at six and i get my ass
kicked so this went on for several years
and i have a big time learning
disability and my dad didn't believe in
us going to school
so
my dad it was about the business the
skating rink and the bar so this game
will open about seven o'clock at night
and this is time i was able to walk so
about five you know four five six years
old eight nine
and i go to this you know skating rink
at seven o'clock at night and i work the
skating rink until 10
at night and then we would scrape the
gum off the floors and we cleaned the
whole skating rink up and then my dad at
the office
and my brother and myself would sleep in
the office and my mom would go upstairs
and work the bar until three o'clock in
the morning and then they cleaned the
bar up so after all that [ __ ] was done
with going to school really happened
so when i went to school i was all kind
of you know my my learning disability i
had
social anxiety i was just a jacked up
kid from living in this tortured home
from the outside looking in we lived in
the all-white neighborhood and then we
would travel to the ghetto of buffalo
new york where the skating rink was at
so we you know we worked around mostly
blacks and i lived around mostly whites
but no one knew what was going on in
that house that on 201 paradise road you
know it's crazy i believe that most
human beings are only living at about 40
of their capability
so
the mind has a governor like a car
if you're driving a car and the car has
a governor on it the car may say 130
miles an hour but the governor's set for
91.
once that governor sets in you get to 91
that car starts doing this the car wants
to go the car wants to go but that
factory said uh-uh we're not going past
91 we have a factory a nice governor in
our brain and it's a survival mechanism
it protects us from pain and suffering
the second we feel that our mind says oh
no this isn't fun
we should back off we should sit down
find something more comfortable and
there's something about the mind the
mind has the tactical advantage over you
at all times
at all times of your life
the mind has a tactical advantage over
you why is that it knows what you're
afraid of it knows your insecurities it
knows your deep dark lies
and it starts to push you away from that
it pushes you in a direction that is
comfortable
the mind
controls everything so what i realized
was that when i was growing up and i was
300 pounds and i got all fat and i got
all insecure
i realized that my mind
kept taking me in this direction when
things got uncomfortable for me when i
was facing my insecurities i was facing
my fears my mind said oh no we have the
tactical advantage we need to get you
separate you from this feeling
this feeling over your life's all about
feelings we want the happy feeling we
don't want that feeling of this sucks
why am i here and you don't have any so
so you can't answer those questions so
you leave
i started realizing that if in that
moment you can answer those [ __ ] up
questions
and you are now in charge of your brain
versus your brain ruling you
that's where all that stuff comes from
so so the 40 rule is all of that you get
to 40
your brain says we're done let's roll
man this is starting to get painful this
is uncomfortable so you sit down
you have to figure out ways and
everybody's different that's how the
book kind of talks about like we all
have these things about you know
five steps to this and in four steps to
this it's a lot more than that that's
all [ __ ]
it's it's a practice that you have to
it's a habit
so if you know that at 40 i'm still you
know i'm feeling pain
at 40 i'm feeling pain that's where the
40 rule kicks in
now it starts okay i'm i'm feeling pain
my mind's saying all this to me is
saying get out of here run flee the
fighter flight kicks in okay we're done
we're not good enough it starts telling
you all these things you start to
believe it because the mind controls all
this is the time where you have to gain
control back of your mind
it's okay let me see if i can go 45
and once you start giving yourself more
and more hope and start realizing okay
the mind starts to be okay what are you
doing we're supposed to be going right
and you're going left
you start then controlling your mind
start finding more in you know in
yourself and it goes from 40 to a lot
further than that but that's the start
of it though get to get to the spot
where your mind is saying stop
wherever that is
get there first and then that's when
that starts to work for you you got to
control yourself in that moment we
believe like so many people before i
give them a workout plan they're talking
about recovery everybody everybody that
hears me speak
they want to go straight to recovery
work out first huh
work out first before you talk to me
about recovery how to recover yeah
work out first we are always looking for
like whenever i talk to people people
take my words
and they and they and they put it in a
way to where
they want to feel comfortable this guy
you know they they they want to put you
in a box
they want to put a title on you
no you're putting a title on me to make
yourself feel better about yourself
if you read this book of mine and you
see where i came from this person was
this person was not built
this this this person was not made by
god
this person sorry this person was built
i made this person
i made this person by diving into the
insecurities that life gave me because
now they're yours they're yours to own
if you're not smart
call yourself dumb
it's okay
because you are
but take that knowledge you put yourself
down if your fat card is so fat i used
to be 300 pounds
we we want to talk so soft to ourselves
we're looking for that recovery day
and that recovery day is everything in
your life
everything in your life is a recovery
day we're looking for it it's not coming
it's not coming
get over that recovery day
and that's the mentality i took with me
and what happened through that process
was all the frivolous things of life
started to float away i used to tell
people lies so they would like me
because i was so insecure
when you start to build yourself up
and start to have the one thing that we
don't have is confidence yeah real
authentic confidence from hard work
everything else goes away you no longer
look
to other people for your self-esteem
validation
you now know
i walk in the room now and i know that
hours and years and decades
i put into david goggins
that's something
it's not on the wall
it's not a trophy on the wall it's not a
male around your neck
it is actually a feeling in your heart
and people why don't you ever smile
i don't have to
yeah
yeah i do have a story look at my face
i'm a very focused person but the thing
i have in my soul and my heart
that's why i need to smile
i don't need to smile i don't need you
to look at me and say oh my god you look
happy because half of us aren't happy
we're giving you something that we think
you want to see
i don't do that anymore
i don't care how you perceive david
goggins because through my journey i
figured out the one piece i was missing
i thought it was cars i thought it was
women i thought it was i thought it was
my i thought was everything the one
piece i was missing was me having the
courage to face myself you made this
decision to self-publish this book yes
sir
right now it's at like number two or
number three on amazon on of all books
right right that just doesn't happen
with a self-published book i see
something that's that's quite off quite
not the same
and that's what i go for
i've this this book is exactly who i am
as a person exactly the way i did this
book is how i've done my almost my
entire life
is i see what is
not the norm
what's impossible with we know what all
the theorists say you shouldn't be doing
this
that's the wrong way to go look in the
mirror and say i'm okay with being
afraid
i'm okay with going on this easy highway
over here the easy highway has all these
[ __ ] signs directions how to get
somewhere and you have to first be
uncomfortable with how you feel about
yourself with that voice that a lot of
us like to run away from we all have it
we all have that voice to say hey man
you know you're you're kind of wimping
out right now you're kind of being a
little punk right now but a lot of us
say okay that's okay
it's okay to tell these little white
lies to ourselves so we first have to
face the real you
the real me is david goggins the real me
is a guy looking at you right now saying
i don't want to [ __ ] be on this show
right now because i used to stutter as a
kid and i'm afraid of that i'm afraid
that here in a second i'm going to start
[ __ ] stammering and stuttering the
whole world is going to know that i have
all these issues
but that's when i see right now okay
goggins you gotta go on this show
that's goggins
goggins is saying okay david goggins
you're a punk
life made you this way we can't live
like this we can't live in fear we can't
live in judgment
we can't be afraid of what the people
right now are looking at me saying about
me we cannot be afraid of that
that's goggins
god is saying
all of you who don't like me who don't
want to and that person then comes in
but you have to be david goggins and say
man i'm afraid of this i'm [ __ ] up
here
life made me this way here
i stutter i i have these issues with
with uh reading and writing and
and i'm i'm fat and i'm insecure
you have to face that in that dark room
in that dark room is who you are
but in that dark room is where you have
to create
another human being that walks out of
that dark room
to face who you are
that's the only way you're going to get
over
all those things you have to create
someone else not like you have two
different personalities it is you
but you have to find strength and that
visualization of almost me
cracking out goggins like almost like
that superman cape like i'm coming out a
different person a person that doesn't
give a [ __ ] about anything who doesn't
care about being judged who knows i'm
weak who knows i'm afraid who says
whatever you think about me take it
whatever i'm here
that's goggins
in the dark room
you face yourself you realize you want
to be better you realize you don't want
to be this weak insecure person in the
world he has all these problems that we
all have
we all have social media is a great
platform to tell you who we want to be
not who we are
so that's where that dark room is i'm
not a big guy on social media you know
i'm just not big on that stuff even
today
i'm just not a big fan of it man i'm a
big uh introvert i get a lot of my
strength from being introverted
and um going out there and doing what i
do is very all this is very difficult
for me man i don't know what do you have
like 600 000 plus on instagram or
something like that yeah and for
somebody who's you're averse to it you
don't like it you hate it you only post
once in a while you don't really
advertise what you're doing at all but
you've grown this huge following of
people who are super interested in what
you're doing well i think it's important
um to do things you don't like and
i am i was very ashamed of my life story
for a long time
i i i didn't want to go out and tell
anybody [ __ ] about me
so that's why i had two people i you
know i created one david goggins and one
goggins right and um i didn't want
people to know that i had all these
issues but after a while people start to
give you these different taglines you
know like you're super human you're
amazing they start i'm like you [ __ ]
don't know anything about me man i'm
this
insecure kid i started realizing there's
a lot of people out here who are going
through a lot of problems
that i once tapped into you know i had a
whole bunch of issues growing up
and you know i i felt compelled to this
you know what
you got to start sharing this stuff man
because people see where you're at today
they see where you're at today they they
see the man you are today this this hard
rock hard human being
show these people where you come from
right as many people as possible i was
praying for cockroaches when i got out
of the air force i sprayed for
cockroaches i was about 297 to be exact
and i saw this discovery channel show on
tv
and i was like and that discovery
channel show was just guys going through
hell week and i saw these guys freezing
a lot of water
and i was like you know what it brought
back memories of me going through pear
rescue training so at 297 pounds i
decided to uh
try to be a navy seal
and to make a long story short i had to
lose 106 pounds in less than three
months
and that's where it became challenging
for me
so i knew to lose 106 pounds in less
than three months
you're looking at 3 500 calories is a
pound
so i was basically doing a whole bunch
of math in my head so i knew if i were
to stop
and be stagnant there was no calories
being burned
so i i was basically trained all day
long
so that's how i went and before i knew
it
i lost the weight well it's that time of
year again we start to feel real happy
why because we're not going to work if
you believe in santa claus and you
celebrate christmas you're looking
forward to santa claus coming down the
chimney giving you some presents it's a
real good time of year so in a good time
of year we start to feel real good about
ourselves so i start to feel great so we
start making promises to ourselves about
hey i'm going to lose some weight i'm
going to do better in school i'm going
to be better here be better there but
guess what happens the real merry
[ __ ] christmas happens when all of
that noise is gone it's quiet and it's
you against you and now all those
endorphins are gone and i promise you
made by getting up early and getting
after it to go lose weight study harder
guess what
it's a lot harder now that repetition
becomes a lot harder now so a lot of us
can't do things on our own so find
somebody in your life so when you throw
that towel in
they throw that [ __ ] back at you
and say you're not done yet
stay true to yourself stay hard as
you're trying to fix yourself
and dig yourself out of this deep hole
that life society and you helped
you helped also
those people who you saw down there in
that hole who were there with you who
your friends and people who you counted
on because you meet the people in the
same situation that you're in in life
those people become your friends and
second you try to get out of that
situation become better those people are
in that in that grave and that doesn't
just yanking at your heels man saying
oh no get out come on back here motherfu
yeah you ain't gonna make me feel like
you getting out of this hole
do you think you are so i get that all
the time now people would constantly
remind me of who i used to be back in
the day when you really sit back at your
life and you are in that dark room
and you're looking at where you started
from and you tell yourself
god dawg man my mom is this way my
stepdad got murdered my dad beat the
[ __ ] out of me
i can't read and write to say my soul
i've lied about it to everybody i've
cheated on all these tests
my god man
and then you put a goal
in your mind
how are you gonna feel man when you
accomplish this goal coming from that
coming from the hell you came from
a lot of people start from a good
starting point they have a good
foundation what if you can surpass all
these mother
we have everybody who was way up here
started up here and you had you started
with no legs you had to grow legs to
even start walking and then crawling and
then running and then you start passing
people and all that's given to them
i had to use all this negative
that was making me weak and horrible as
a person
i had to use this as the power that now
fueled me had to flip it on his head and
say hold up
this might be exactly what i need
the darkness
is exactly what i need is how you look
at your situation is i have the ability
to see the end
before the beginning even begins
and what that means is i know that to
get to the very end i can see it right
now so before i went to butts and i was
losing all the [ __ ] weight and [ __ ] i
saw myself walking across the stage
at 191 pounds that's what i had to get
to to get into the door
i saw myself
six months a year later whatever's going
to take me to do i saw myself walking
across that stage getting that
certificate of graduation from buds
and i was able to be there
at 300 pounds
and that feeling that i was nowhere near
that [ __ ] feeling i was able to put
myself there
a million times every [ __ ] day and
that feeling of like my god
that is going to feel amazing that's
what made me suffer
that's what allowed the pain to be real
and say this is worth it i want to feel
for this [ __ ] next 18 months it took
me 18 [ __ ] months to finally become a
navy to finally you know just get
through butts 18 months it's six months
took me 18.
that's what woke me up every [ __ ]
morning was i'm gonna put myself through
this much pain and suffering for a few
seconds
that's all it is
a few seconds of joy
is so worth it man i said people don't
get so i'm able to put myself at the
finish line even though i have no finish
line
but at the finish line of an event
before i even start the mother say how
are you going to fill it into this
visualizing this is my biggest tool of
life
that's why i i've been able to
put myself in cold water put myself in a
hundred mile race
millions of times before i've done it
and i'm able to go through the race and
see i'm gonna feel at my 50 almost to
the almost to the exact
exact feeling right so when it comes up
it's no surprise no surprise i've
already done this a million times what
was the greatest lesson your mom taught
you growing up
honestly the greatest lesson she ever
taught me is a lesson that she
she doesn't know how much she taught me
because she wasn't much in the teaching
mode
my dad took her soul but what i did as a
young kid
is i observed
everybody
i wasn't really smart in the books yeah
but i was real smart when it came to
life yeah and i was able to sit back and
watch her mistakes i was able to see
how she struggled through life
and how i don't want to struggle through
life
and i was able to see
she never picked me up the biggest thing
she did for me and this is honest to god
truth and she doesn't even know she did
it
but i would bust my ass and i would fail
yeah when i was at the bottom of the
sewer
she never picked me up
she never gave me that cookie and said
hey son you know it's gonna be okay
never she didn't have time for that
and sometimes she gets upset when i talk
about my past because it pains her out
to be not the best mom
if i had any kind of mom in that kind of
environment
i would have never made it
because
she forced me for every reason
she forced me
to you better figure this out
or you're gonna be a statistic
and this is something that she didn't
sit down to tell me
i realized this this is the world that
is in front of me
and what most people do is they see this
world
and they look at it as an excuse to get
out of it
yeah
i started looking at it
as this is the ultimate training ground
for the rest of my life
i have all these valuable lessons
because if you look out in the world
right now today it's not a nice place
but i'm very prepared for it yeah you
are i prepared for it i'm prepared for
all the failure coming my way
i'm prepared for everything my way and
that's the biggest lesson that she
taught me by not teaching me
by never saying it's going to be okay
matter of fact she told me the exact
opposite life sucks you are your own
hero
you are your own leader you are your own
master
and
that is a big one because
we idolize so many people
and we want to be them
we want to be someone else
and in doing that
you lose all the potential of who you
are
you
mimic
you be them you are them you become them
and you lose you
and we look up to so many people in this
world who will let us down we're humans
i'm going to let you down you're going
to let somebody down if you put them on
a pedestal you then lose time when that
person comes up and lets you down
you must hold yourself accountable and
being your own hero that's what that
does
you make yourself so
totally accountable for who you are you
focus on you and only on you
to become the best person you could be
for others
because we leave a lot on the table
not searching who we are
and then therefore you die not knowing
your greatest potential so i'm sitting
there and i think i'm i think i'm gonna
die
and we're saving my life
and i'm in this tub and i'm
jackhammering and this and i had this
hot water hitting me and i'm literally
in the worst pain my my shins my feet
i'm broken
and i'm just sitting i'm cramping up
and she said we gotta get to the doctor
you know your mom's worried i don't
worry about like i we've
never seen this for my life
and i go
i'm not going
anywhere huh
i want to sit here and enjoy this pain
and and
i and i know
the listeners hearing this are going to
say man you're not no i'm not
what i
got a chance to experience
in that 19 hours and six minutes of my
life
was something i didn't want any
painkillers i i this was proof positive
what i was feeling is what i just did
i
i did something
without training without coaching
without a cheering staff without any
knowledge
i took a raw
human being with no training whatsoever
put him out in a condition
and just through this alone
got through it amazing and i sat there
and i was like
this is it was the best feeling
i've ever had and will ever have in my
entire i was in the worst pain in my
life and it was the best feeling
i ever had in my life not because of the
pain i was in
by the pain was confirmation
of my god
did i just do that wow and i had
completed hell weeks
but that right there was like don't take
this from me man and and it was
confirmation proof positive
that
this young kid that came from that
wasn't [ __ ] that lied and cheated for
i was now
the truth the one major question i got
was
how do i finish where i start
i get two weeks into it
and then i stop
well there's the thing about it
people forget one thing about me i used
to be you i used to be a fat guy
i gotta didn't care much i gotta got d's
and f's in school i gotta blame other
people a guy that was under
under mediocre
i wasn't even average
so this is the thing about it
i'm going to tell you what people don't
want to tell you
why you stop
is because you're lazy
it's because you don't mind
getting bad grades in school it doesn't
bother you enough to be mediocre to be
average
to sit around
and watch people do great things
you don't mind it so there's your answer
your answer is you don't care enough
about yourself so you don't stay in the
fight stay hard if you want to know the
one simple trick to persevere even when
you want to quit check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there on the struggle to get to this
moment
your mind has a tactical advantage over
you at all times it knows your
weaknesses it knows your strengths and
it will guide you into your nice comfort
zone